[Music]
from the man responsible for every movie
your girlfriend tried to drag you to
comes the Phil responsible for every bad
movie about a dozen famous people
falling in love on a popular holiday
Love Actually this holiday season
prepare for the ultimate romantic comedy
that's not very romantic or funny or
relevant to the holiday season and I'm
the lobster in a nativity play
but don't worry sit through it and you
still might get laid follow along on
this pulp fiction for girls stuffed with
eight different pot lines that are
creepy and depressing when you actually
stop to think about them like a man
getting over the death of his wife
by helping his kids seduce a girl with
the same name as his dead mom
her name's Chyna seem his mom a woman
who ends up alone with her unstable
brother instead of her heart available
coworker this guy who's trying to bang
his best friend's wife wait is that Rick
do you think Karl knows oh oh a man who
will throw away his loving wife and
children to buy a necklace for this
walking vagina
well if that Corner's fool in dark deeds
a powerful older man who fires a
subordinate for being distracting Lee
Hodge a powerful older man whose wife
cheats on him so he seduces his young
hot subordinate who doesn't even speak
English good thank you
vennett and these two uncomfortable
standings on the highest budget porno of
all time experience what boils down to a
super cut of every rom-com cliche in the
book
the last-minute airport - awkward meet
use Junction fasteners just murdered
gridlock this morning making out behind
the curtain and getting discovered
singing in public Good King Wenceslas
looked out adorable children over the
top gestures and Hugh Bing grant so this
Christmas catch one of the most
subversive chick flicks of all time
that's aimed at a female audience but
tells them the ideal woman brings you
food and occupy isn't fair the chubby
girl he said I was getting fat come on
later Pompey I think there's a pretty
sizable ass there yes sir huge thighs
and shows you her boobs
thanks bro starring all these people you
like better and other things rigged and
for real I'm telling you that's totally
rigged Bilbo Baggins from The Hobbit
qui-gon jinn Hans Gruber Davy Jones Kim
Bauer
professor Taurani Liz Shaw from Doctor
Who Nadia from American Pie Betty Draper
Xerxes
Carmen from Starship Troopers Bad Santa
of course mr. beans at it Jojen Reed
Elizabeth from Pirates of the Caribbean
and the voice of Marceline on adventure
time Wow all that's missing is someone
from Breaking Bad oh [ __ ] it's the gray
matter guy from Breaking Bad bingo I
have bingo actually
yo saw it go
my stone exactly be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers number one I
order you to take a number two I don't
walk into clubs the clubs walk into me I
will not succumb to your pelvic sorcery
if we burn you burn with us I'm sorry
Dave I'm afraid I can't do that
I like shorts they are confit and easy
to wear
bacon pancakes makin bacon pancakes get
some bacon and put them in a pancake